[Music] he's someone that's coming with a lot
of expectation you wanted highlights you got
highlights the there's a lot of anticipation
and nerves that come with that first game try
not to focus on it too much you don't really
know what the emotions would be in that moment
that's just part of playing your first game
especially in his situation but it's fun we all
remember our first game the 18yearold Superstar
brings an incredible passion to this game of
hockey welcome to the Crosby [Applause]
show I grew up being a huge fan of Crosby
his determination and competitiveness on the ice
and the way he carries himself off the ice really
easy to look up to him there's a a lot of weight
on your shoulders if you want exceptional there's
exceptional outside noise something that I'm
never thinking about he seems like he's ready and
excited for the challenge I'm focused on hockey
and I'm trying to be the best I can be definitely
playing against him all the eyes are on it and
you get up to those match [Applause] ups let's
go